all right so Transformers rise of the
beasts is gonna be the big summer
blockbuster next year and we wanted to
go over everything we know of these
mechanical mammals going fisticuffs with
the other robots in Disguise along with
some potential leaks that may give us a
better idea of what this latest
Transformers may have in store but no
worries we'll warn you when any sort of
borderline spoiler is coming up so with
that out of the way a huge thank you for
clicking this I'm your host to Jared now
let's get into Transformers rise of the
beasts you've never faced anything like
this
let them come so to get the wheels
moving rise of the Beast will be taking
a heavy inspiration from one of my
favorite 90s animated shows Beast Wars
Transformers in this we saw robotic
descendants of the Autobots and
Decepticons properly named the maximals
and the Predacons get sucked through a
Time Warp essentially crash into Earth
millions of years before civilization
they take the form of animals rather
than the traditional vehicles and
aircrafts now it's been confirmed that
the rise of the beasts takes place in
1994 being a sequel to 2018's Bumblebee
which was set in 1987 however it does
not appear that Haley steinfeld's
Charlie character will be making a
return for this movie with word that
rise of the beasts is the first in a new
Transformers Trilogy unfortunately for
all you bayham fans out there this isn't
going to connect to the Michael Bay
films that ruled the box office in the
late 2000s and 2010s but with this
taking place 20 some years before those
movies there could be some Sly
Connections in Easter eggs who knows now
the first trailer for this which we did
a huge breakdown for and you can click
it right up there hints at the max
Smalls and Predacons already having a
presence here on Earth with the modern
day Autobots and Decepticons unaware of
their existence this is then gonna blend
the different generations of the
original Transformers from the 80s with
the newer animal versions of each
respective faction surprisingly though
the main villains of this film aren't
supposed to be the Predacons or
Decepticons but rather the terror cons
all of this may sound like gobbledygoop
to anyone aware of the Beast War series
but let's break it down for you so the
maximals are essentially the equivalent
to the Autobots mostly taking the form
of mammals birds or fish while the
Predacons are essentially the
Decepticons taking the form of reptiles
amphibians and insects while the tear
Terror cons are a subgroup of disbanded
Decepticons essentially living on their
own code of ethics when promoting the
film producer Lorenzo Day bonaventura
added we get to pair everyone up against
each other so it becomes a grand finale
epic Transformers experience when the
terracons disrupt our movie you're gonna
feel it but it's really the terracons
who are the leading villains but reeling
things back a bit in order to get this
Mega Showdown rise of the beasts takes
place in mainly 90s Brooklyn New York
introducing Anthony Ramos's character of
Noah Diaz as the Sam wit Wiki of this
film said to be an ex-military
Electronics expert supporting his family
where he comes across the autobot of
Mirage Mirage being a staple of the
franchise throughout some of the other
films and Series this time sporting the
look of a silver blue Porsche 964 and
voiced by SNL lump Pete Davidson upon
befriending Mirage Noah is introduced a
handful of other Autobots that we can
see in the first trailer including
Optimus Prime voiced by Peter Cullen RC
voiced by Liza koshy who appears to be
the female Commando holding onto the
brown Volkswagen panel bus the
Volkswagen is an Autobot as well being
the scientist of wheel Jack voiced by
Christo Fernandez and of course our
lovable yellow Corvette bumblebee we
also know Dominique Fishback will be
another leading human character by the
name of Elena said to be an artifact
researcher at a New York City Museum
whose boss kind of keeps taking credit
for all of her work I'm assuming Noah
and the Autobots will seek out her help
to research some sort of artifact that
will then lead them to Peru which is
said to be where a decent portion of the
movie takes place and according to the
trailer this is where the maximals will
reveal themselves to Noah Elena and
Optimus again maximals are the animal
versions of Autobots and going to
include Optimus primal a giant gorilla
and a great pun of a name voiced by Ron
Perlman air raiser a peregrine falcon
Voice by Michelle Yao rhinox of course a
rhinoceros who is the tech expert of the
maximals and voiced by David sobolov
along with chitar a cheetah who is said
to be kind of the Rookie of the maximal
team these two forces will team up going
against the Decepticons Predacons and
the main villains terracons now the
leader of the terracons is going to be
Scourge a voiced by Peter Dinklage
taking the form of a Peterbilt 359
logging semi truck so if the look of
this vehicle isn't evil enough for you
Scourge is said to be a Trophy Hunter
collecting Autobots and maximal pieces
almost hunting like sport producer D
bonaventura added one of the cool
features that Steven came up with that
Scourge basically takes the insignias
off of the robots that he's killed and
fuses them onto his body so he's like a
living Memorial of the Havoc he's
created meaning Scourge will physically
display his kill count on his body with
director cable adding I wanted to dabble
more in the horror in this one and make
people actually jump out of their seats
when they see certain things so it
sounds like this will be one heck of a
battle bot Royale between the three or
or I guess five factions again this
movie is releasing in theaters on June
9th 2023 in the heart of Summer movie
season so it appears that they are
gearing up for one heck of a Blockbuster
Movie now in the next part of this film
I want to talk about some of the
potential plot leaks characters and
other things that give us a better idea
of what the heck is going down in this
concrete jungle of Rise of the beasts
this is your spoiler warning cars
spoilers you know so if you don't want
to have anything ruined for you for this
upcoming Transformers movie I would
recommend you shift into fifth gear and
speed out of here right now now again I
would take all of this with a grain of
salt as these leaks may not be a hundred
percent true but it is rumored that the
main plot of the film is the differing
factions trying to obtain the warp Keys
similar to the original plot of the
Beast Wars animated series and the
Golden Disc the motivations between each
faction seem to be a bit different with
the Autobots wanting to return back home
to Cybertron but Scourge and the
terracons want to bring Unicron to Earth
essentially an extra dimensional entity
twin to Primus to claim the planet said
to be sort of switching things up from
your traditional Autobots versus
Decepticons matchup even though the
Rivalry is supposed to be present in the
film with Optimus initially having a
run-in with a no-name d level Decepticon
to set the stage for the robot versus
robot action it also sounds like Optimus
is a younger more jaded distrustful
version of the leader of the Autobots
than we've seen in the Bay films he
isn't too fond of the humans but
apparently his mentality changes
throughout the film later becoming the
more of a protector that we've seen of
him and of the planet one of the biggest
heartbreaks is the rumored exclusion of
any real Predacons yeah I mentioned that
this is like a weird thrupple angle
happening in the film with Hiro and
villain team-ups but the only real
Predacon or Predacon looking creatures
are big Scorpions similar to scorponok
that was featured in the original Beast
War series however they actually aren't
that predicon instead generic creatures
for them to fight the human element of
the film is said to be at a minimum
though which I always thought was the
weakest part of the Bay films so there's
supposed to be no military involvement
like bumblebee instead the film is
solely Anthony Ramos and Dominique
fishback's character of Noah and Elena
as they help the Autobots recover the
trans warp or warp keys that are needed
though rumored not to add much to the
film fishback's character is a museum in
turn rather than researcher solely there
to interpret maximal hieroglyphs to help
them recover these keys and realmus's
character seems to be brought into the
mix by Mirage resembling a Sam and B
relationship from the first Transformers
films so I'm guessing Mirage is going to
be the Catalyst between the autobots and
the humans to show one another that they
can be trusted and protecting now
bumblebee also apparently reinforces
these feelings upon Optimus as being a
protector for the humans assuming
because he's had these adventures with
the humans before in the Bumblebee movie
however it's never really reference or
there's not a nod to that movie which
feels a bit strange I mentioned earlier
Peru was another big location in the
film and apparently the warp keys or one
of them is what drives them to this
place said that Noah Elena and others
fly aboard a cargo ship that is later
revealed to be the Transformer
Stratosphere voiced by John Dimaggio
with a Scottish accent and the ship
lands close to Machu Picchu trying to
recover a key before the Terracon at
some point in the movie it's rumored
that air razor is attacked by the
terracons hacked and then is turned evil
I vaguely remember something along these
lines happening in the Animated Beast
War series but again this is supposed to
lead to the final showdown with Scourge
and a couple of other terracons
activating a giant Avengers style portal
beam into the sky and fighting against
the maximals and Autobots there's also
some rumored inter-relationship details
amongst some of the Autobots and
maximals like an implied relationship
between RC and wheel Jack that we can
kind of see in the trailer footage here
or there but it goes a little further in
playing sexual innuendos between the
pair like going 69 and a 55 which feels
like it's not too far off from you know
like the Megan Fox Bay film days the
leaks also suggests that Primal and air
razor are sort of the main Max most
Primal with the help of chitor and
rhinox are tasked with guarding one of
keys in Machu Picchu and sort of has to
teach optimists that humans can be
trusted while air razor is kind of a
wise Maximo you know one to keep a level
head however is there to supply a lot of
the exposition to the film now just like
Optimus had his roll out moment in
previous films the maximals are supposed
to and I'm so excited for this have
their maximized transform moment which I
hope is as hype as the 2017 Power
Rangers go go Power Rangers moment as we
mentioned this is supposed to be the
start of a new Transformers Trilogy and
they're supposed to be a mid-credits
scene teasing the next film featuring
Unicron which of course is what the
terracons were rumored to be motivated
into bringing to Earth unfortunately
time travel which played a huge role in
the original Beast Wars series may
actually be absent from the entire plot
which seems a bit odd to explain how
maximals and Predacons have been here in
the first place but again these are the
leaks take everything with a grain of
salt anyway that is everything we know
about the Transformers rise of the
beasts movie what are your thoughts on
Rise of the Beast were you a big fan of
the 90s Beast Wars series or has the
Transformers franchise veered too far
off the road and I'll let you know we're
currently running a competition right
now giving away three copies of Black
Adam and Dawn of the Dead on the 15th of
January and all you got to do to get a
chance of winning this is like this
video subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment Down Below on your
thoughts of Rise of the beasts we picked
the comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of last month are
on screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our huge
breakdowns we've done recently
Interstellar Logan the thing lots of
stuff with that out of the way thank you
for your constant support I've been
Jared I'll see in the next one take care
and peace